welcome back to Hannity we are in
Davenport Iowa with a massive fun crowd
a rowdy crowd and with GOP front runner
uh president Donald Trump let me let me
just throw out a list of some of the
significant issues that we're facing as
a country and and you've touched on a
number of them uh you mentioned borders
day one you mentioned energy day one uh
look at where our economy is last year
two trillion in debt 38 trillion over uh
34 trillion overall we this year Mr
President will pay before we spend a
dime $1
trillion on debt service alone before
Medicare Social Security National
Defense that is unsustainable yeah so
before Co hit us our gift uh from China
that was our gift what happened to us
with Co commonly known as the China
virus they don't like that but it was a
CH
virus we were doing energy taking our
liquid gold out of the ground at a rate
that's never been seen before and it was
going up we were going to be using that
Liquid Gold to sell to Europe instead of
the pipeline from Russia which I exposed
and I stopped you know I stopped that
line then they say I was nice to Russia
there was nobody that was nice I was not
nice to Russia I stopped that pipeline
we would have been selling oil and gas
to Europe to Asia all over the world we
would have been paying off debt that
debt would be way down right now because
we have more what people don't know we
have more Liquid Gold than any other
country in the world by far and we
started off in fourth place we were
number four it was Saudi Arabia it was
Russia it was two countries fighting for
number three and it was us at number
four or five by the time I left we were
number one by 25% we would have been
number one by a 100 and we would have
done twice what they were going to do
combined we would have been paying off
debt and we would have been reducing
taxes we gave you the biggest tax cut in
the history of our country bigger than
the Reagan tax cut we would have been
reducing taxes still further and that's
why Sean that's why we had the most jobs
of any president ever because we gave
the we got rid of regulations tremendous
no president got rid of more regulations
or close and we gave you the big tax cut
so everybody had incentive and everybody
was happy and everybody was working I
remember groups came to see me that
wouldn't normally like me and they said
we've never seen anything like it we
were actually starting to get along that
we got hit with the China virus we were
some people think think purposely I
don't I think it was incompetence but
some people think purposely because we
were doing so much better than any other
country ever and we got hit but I will
tell you we would be paying that debt
off right now at levels like never seen
before and would have been beautiful
thing you brought us to energy
Independence for the first time in 75
years before you ran I remember we had
many discussions about energy
independence energy Independence and
you're saying that you would in a second
term you will push America to be the
most energy dominant country on Earth
and that you could pay down that $34
trillion in debt and we won't have a
trillion dollar interest payment every
year that's right we would get it way
down and you know look
so it's Biden inflation that's what it
is what he did with energy is
unbelievable because energy went up so
much gasoline $5 $6 a gallon that that's
what caused inflation now it's all over
the place but you have
29% total inflation now when it holds up
because the economy is starting to slow
down very substantially so when it holds
up he's saying well we don't have too
much inflation but he doesn't talk about
all of the inflation that you've had to
suffer over the last three years no we
will have numbers like you've never seen
we ever thing in Alaska called anoir
Ronald Reagan tried to get it approved
everybody to Bush maybe a little bit you
know he didn't work as hard but we have
we have anoir in Alaska the biggest
anywhere in the world including probably
Saudi Arabia I got it approved I was so
proud of it they ended it in the first
week they ended it they turn we'll get
it back but we have more than anybody we
have more wealth than anybody but we
don't use it and then guys like des
santis and guys like many of the
Democrats but guys like d santis and to
a lesser extent Nikki Haley they want to
play a around with your Social Security
you don't have to touch Social Security
we have money laying in the ground far
greater than anything we can do by
hurting senior citizens with their
social
security Ronda santis wanted to bring up
on Social Security now of course he says
well I wouldn't but you know one thing I
learned about politicians I've known
them I've dealt with them on the other
side for a long time they first thought
is always the thought that they go to he
wanted to raise the minimum age the age
on social security to 70 that's a big
increase but he also wanted to raise it
to 75 if that happened people would be
devastated we have such incredible
wealth under our feet that that takes
care of everything it will take care you
know if you go to Saudi Arabia and they
bought many boeings many planes and I
said to them do you use financing for
that they didn't even know what the word
meant they have so much money they have
a fund $21 trillion it's all for oil and
we have more oil and gas than they do
our country can be rich again John kery
has to be stopped he's destroying our
country this
guy I mean think of it he goes all over
the world in a private jet by the way he
goes all over the world talking to these
people about getting rid of call plants
they all laugh at him they you know
treat him with respect he's gone they
say what an idiot what a jerk and then
they go ahead and they build their coal
plants he goes to China about uh let's
say say uh the atmosphere he talks about
global warming he talks about all you
know they don't call it global warming
so much now they call it climate change
because it wasn't working global warming
wasn't working when it was cooling so
now they call it climate change that
takes care of everything I am an
environmentalists but we're going to
destroy our country with this green New
Deal stuff that doesn't work just to
finish we have so much wealth and power
under our feet no other country has it
China doesn't have it why are we going
to Electric they do have what you need
to do the batteries but they don't have
what you need to do the gasoline we have
and it's what it's what people want to
drive right now and there's a little
story about it but you're going to see
it a lot I guarantee you they have so
many electric vehicles nobody wants to
buy them they're expensive alth they
probably get them Che now nobody wants
to buy them 3,000 dealers around the
country wrote Biden and said please stop
making us sell something they don't want
Ford lost $4.5 billion let me ask you
this you know the government is
subsidizing that a lot they a lot saying
every time you make a car we give you
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars and the people don't want them
and you know I'm not knocking electric
cars we should sell electric but we
should also sell uh combustion engine
gasoline cars we can sell hybrids the
hybrids are fine we should be able to
buy everything some people might like an
electric car we should be able to buy an
electric car but to say that we're not
going to do and this is our strength
because we have this stuff under the
ground and we have people going around
really destroying our country they're
destroying our country at the border
they've they will allow in my opinion
because you don't hear the real numbers
15 million people into our country by
the time Biden gets out which hopefully
will be very soon if they get another
term this country is finished by the
time he gets out and the people people
are coming from prisons all over the
world they're coming from mental
institutions all over the world and
they're terrorists and this country is
going to be suffering a very big price
it's amazing that it hasn't happened and
interestingly I had very strong borders
the strongest ever we had the strongest
Border in history all they had to do is
leave leave Brandon Jud and leave Tom
homman and leave all these guys weers
yeah we had the strongest bers in let
put this on the screen go ahead we Iran
is the number one state sponsor of
Terror right okay well foreign Nationals
founded our Southern border because of
Joe Biden's open borders from Iran 659
from Syria 538 from Afghanistan
6,386 Egypt
3,153
12,605 from Russia
26113 from China now can you explain to
me do you what do you think the odds are
that among that group of people from our
top geopolitical foes in most cases yeah
that Terror cells have entered the
country because of the 8 million people
Joe Biden has allowed into this country
unvetted what are the odds the odds are
100% look why do we have 26,000 how
scary is that think of it it's 100 no
it's 100% And by the way we had nothing
during my remember I had the travel ban
I said I don't want people coming from
countries that want to blow us up and we
put a travel ban and some people thought
I was discriminating but if you think
about it I went four years with no
problem we didn't have any problem we
didn't have buildings being knocked down
we didn't have World Trade Centers we
didn't have any of that we had no we had
a very strong travel ban and if you came
from a country that was a country I can
tell you right now I can name every one
of them we just didn't want you I'm
sorry and we actually had it passed by
the Supreme Court and that was a big day
but we didn't have a problem hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else